- Oh, it is dark!
Oh my god.
- Wow!
(techno music)
- And you said this is
some type of weird kinky
thing that some white people are doing?
- We're just kind of jamming whatever
comes our way in our mouths.
- This is so weird! Eww!
- I don't know where to put my eyes.
- This is super creepy.
- I'm hungry, so this
better not be horrible.
- Here, it's here.
Come here.
- Ahh
- It's feels like a nut!
- It feels like it's chocolate.
- Hazelnut!
- A cashew?
- We're like the daredevil right now
we're blind, but our taste
our sense of smell and taste
is just like heightened
to a superhero degree.
- Aww (laughs)
- What?
- I hate it already.
- You ate it?
- No, I hate it.
- Oh, hate it!
- It's slimy.
- What is this?
- Oh, it's wet!
- Oh, oh
- Watermelon?
- Mango?
- I think it's a peach.
- I think you're close.
- It's like an apricot?
- Cantaloupe?
- This is a cantaloupe?
- Honey dew melon?
- Wow! It's so weird when
you can't see anything.
- I didn't want to touch it anymore.
- Whatever this is.
It tastes much better in the dark.
- Is it like kiwi?
- Kiwi!
- High five.
- Ah, that was my head!
(laughs)
- I'll tell you right now, I hate it.
- Oh, no!
- I don't want to swallow this.
- Ah, This is evil!
(laughs)
- Oh yeah, oh, oh!
Oh, It's hot!
- My tongue hurts.
- Is this ginger?
- It's ginger
- Oh, my fucking god!
- It's definitively ginger.
- Can I get a tissue?
(laughs)
- This is strawberry.
No, it's not.
- There's a new one?
Oh god, I'm so behind.
- Ew!
- It tastes bizarre, right?
- Woah
- I think it might be hearts of palm.
- What the hell is that?
- I have no idea.
- It smells like corn, doesn't it?
- Not at all
(laughs)
- No?
- Take that guys
(laughs)
- This is madness!
- That was a beet?
- I think that's probably
normal, isn't it?
Just a chunk full of beet.
- This is like what your grandmother eats.
She's like here take some beets.
And you're like no.
(laughs)
- This is--
- I'm like trying to coordinate.
- This is so silly!
- Here we go.
- You have a nice a nice scruff.
- Here you go incoming.
Boom.
(laughs)
- It's cheese.
- My finger was in your mouth.
(laughs)
- A sign of a good day.
- Gruyère?
- Manchego cheese?
- I am not a foodie, I don't
know any of these terms.
- Woah, that is like a hockey bag!
- Parmessan!
(claps)
- It tastes better when
you're being fed cheese.
- This a weird Freudian thing
that happened right there.
(laughs)
- Something about eating in the dark
just added this really kind of sexy--
- Yeah
- Element of danger to the food.
- Yes
- It's very weird!
(laughs)
- Like I've been usually
scared of the texture of food.
- Try it, because I
actually really like this.
I love like heightened
senses and this was just
the epitome of it.
- Okay
- Stop
- Three, two
- No, no we'll just start right here.
- Oh, okay and two.
(claps)